Apple says it's got a new breakthrough
product advancing the world of virtual
reality it's a new headset called Vision
Pro that allows users to access apps
from their iPhones and control them with
eye and hand movements yep that's what
they say but the new device has a big
price tag 3 500 Carter Evans looks now
at the product and its chances of
success in a competitive VR Market
this marks the beginning of a journey
Apple wants you to wear its next
groundbreaking product on your face
Apple Vision Pro relies solely on your
eyes hands and voice it's just you and
your content it's an entire computer and
packed into a headset giving you a front
row 3D seat to an augmented reality that
includes apps photos even movies
Apple wants to emphasize that you can
still see the real world wired senior
writer Lauren good was at the launch
event it seems like their positioning it
as something that people would want to
wear all day long VR launches by
Microsoft Google and Facebook now meta
have faltered or failed and Apple's
headsets will take a bite out of your
budget
a hundred dollars kids aren't going to
be unwrapping this for their birthday no
I mean this is really aimed at the
developer Community Tech analyst Dan Ive
says those developers will likely design
thousands of never before seen apps this
is the start of a new Apple it's a whole
nother view of where they're going from
a technology perspective over the next
decade when Vision Pro comes out next
year Apple expects it to overcome
similar skepticism that first greeted
the iPhone hoping people will come to
embrace this new face of technology for
CBS mornings I'm Carter Evans
I think it's cool that you can make it
as big as you want I do think there's
something so if anybody can do it it
would be apple it is cool but until VR
is something you can eat and drink in I
think it has limitations